[Música]
[Aplausos]
vengo a hablar los de cómo dar la vuelta
al mundo y cómo darle la vuelta
a tu mundo desde el año 2001 he estado
viajando por el mundo en bicicleta he
usado seis pasaportes aquí os voy a
mostrar apenas 4
la primera foto que vais a ver es una
persona parecida a mí hace más de 20
años con raya a un lado
trabajaba en una notaría en honor a esa
persona hoy me he vuelto a poner el
traje para recordar de dónde vengo
ya os contaré la historia de cómo dejé
el trabajo y cómo poco a poco el pelo se
fue desmelenando al mismo tiempo que la
sonrisa cada vez era mayor
esto es lo que ocurre cuando decides
perseguir tus sueños más profundos
yo me reencarne para reencarnarse no
hace falta morir físicamente
hace falta observarse
y de la muerte quería hablaros sabéis
qué
en pleno siglo 21 la esperanza de vida
supera los 80 años y sin embargo hay más
suicidios que homicidios no hay el doble
y el triple no no hay 10 veces más pero
es que según el instituto nacional de
estadística el año pasado en nuestro
país entre los millennials que son los
que tienen entre 15 y 39 quién los
pillara
el suicidio fue la causa mayor de muerte
vivimos en un propósito vivimos
esperando que llegue el fin de semana
cuando yo trabajaba en la oficina la
notaría en mi escritorio venían las
personas a hacer testamento hola buenas
tardes buenas tardes venía a hacer
testamento por si me muero yo sonreía y
decía por cierta sed ahora inserta
la muerte es cierta en el sí pero
incierta en el cuándo va a ocurrir
tenemos fecha de caducidad como los
yogures la fecha hasta aquí debajo de la
tapa no la sabemos pero está escrita el
día la hora y el lugar la gente se
asustaba tocaba madera la mesa no yo no
no es madera es chapa da nada más
qué falta de seriedad en una notaría de
verdad ahí empecé a comprender cómo la
gente no le mira a los ojos a la muerte
y es un error muy grande debería
hablarse de la muerte en las escuelas
deberíais hablar de la muerte en casa
porque la muerte decía steve jobs es el
principal agente de cambio porque vamos
a morir
tenemos que despertar no podemos esperar
a que llegue el fin de semana si hoy
lunes no estás haciendo lo que te gusta
revisa tu vida dale la vuelta a tu mundo
analiza que falla haz una estrategia por
una fecha y cámbialo no sigamos
caminando con una piedra en el zapato
para te saca la piedra y continúa
tenemos continuamente que ajustar
nuestra vida a nuestro propósito dice
pablo doors que lo malo no es morir
evidentemente todos vamos a morir lo
malo es hacerlo sin haber vivido lo malo
es morir sin cumplir tus sueños tu
propósito el que sea el mío
fue un poco exagerado
y vivir en una bicicleta y recorrer el
mundo el vuestro puede ser ser padres de
familia es un propósito excelente pero
una cosa
tenéis que ser los mejores padres de
familia y mirar a vuestro alrededor
tenéis competencia hagáis lo que hagáis
hacerlo con pasión con pasión
si vais a robar que no sea una carterita
una anciana en la puerta del sol que sea
el banco de españa'
echárselo todo a la vida no guardéis
nada no guardéis nada
estudié derecho prepare oposiciones a
notarías aprobé varios exámenes no
conseguí aprobar la oposición pero no
fracase y sabéis porque en la vida no se
fracasa cuando entregas todo lo que
tienes todo me deje la piel yo nunca
supe que podía llegar a memorizar 1976
artículos del código civil con puntos y
comas la ley hipotecaria el código de
comercio leyes autonómicas que máquina
aprendí a conocerme y aprendí a
retirarme aposté cinco años no lo
conseguí y lo dejé y encontré trabajo en
una notaría y ahí descubrí la
importancia de vivir con propósito como
veréis pero porque necesitamos un
propósito cómo encontrar ese propósito
porque te levantas cada mañana que hace
que te levantes
que falta menos para las vacaciones
danielle pink en su libro drive habla de
tres tipos de motivación motivación
biológica es la del hombre de neandertal
te levantas porque tienes que beber y
comer bien espero que ninguno en la sala
tenga ese tipo de motivación eso está
cubierto el descubrió otra motivación
motivación la extrínseca
si a la gente le ponemos esto delante de
las narices va a venir a trabajar bueno
a veces sí a veces no de hecho prueba
darle a tu hijo dinero para que saque la
basura y verás como la semana que viene
te hace huelga en el pasillo pidiendo un
aumento de sueldo
la motivación extrínseca motivar con
dinero no funciona cuando se trata de
trabajos creativos es más mata la
creatividad según el neurocientífico
knutson bryant de la universidad de
stanford tan mencionada el dinero
provoca en el cerebro el mismo efecto
que la cocaína
genera adicción
aumenta la visión a corto plazo
genera que asuma riesgos innecesarios y
mata como he dicho la creatividad
motivar con dinero no funciona
no funciona y daniel habla de la
motivación intrínseca que es la que de
verdad funciona es la gasolina a largo
plazo porque porque te motiva desde el
interior eres tú el que te marca los
límites autonomía de gestión tú marcas
los plazos autonomía de medios tú marcas
cómo hacerlo interesa amábile en un
artículo de la harvard business review
dice que el deseo de hacer algo porque
te mueve porque es un reto personal
inspira los más altos niveles de
creatividad y es curioso la gente se
mata buscando la felicidad y la
felicidad está detrás de un muro que se
llama propósito encuentra un propósito y
llegarás a la felicidad
sebastian coe medallista olímpico no
corría para ganar medallas corría para
hacer lo mejor y más rápido cada vez
como consecuencia ganaba la medalla pero
no era su objetivo su objetivo es ser
mejor cuando eres mejor persona todo te
va bien pero si tratas de que te vaya
bien a toda costa todo te va mal
este es el botón más importante que
tenéis en vuestra vida este botón el de
la pausa es gratis
usarlo por favor usarlo varias veces al
día yo lo he hecho varias veces al día
y funciona
hay dos herramientas fundamentales para
encontrar el propósito del
autoconocimiento y la autorreflexión y
las dos pasan por este botón yo aprendí
en las oposiciones a notarías la
capacidad enorme que tengo de
estudiar de memorizar mi gran fuerza de
voluntad mi gran determinación mi gran
perseverancia entregué todo me conocí
como persona y la autorreflexión viene
cuando le das al botón para y piensa
para y piensa hay tres reglas
fundamentales para conseguir un
propósito para descubrir tu propósito s
ss la primera s speed velocidad uno de
mis documentales se llama a la velocidad
de las mariposas incluso las mariposas
me adelantaban en muchas subidas en
puertos de montaña
dice el filósofo coreano bien surjan en
un libro que os recomiendo el aroma del
tiempo que la vida acelerada que lleva
el ser humano hoy en día impide la vida
contemplativa si no te paras a
contemplar cómo quieres saber dónde vas
cómo vas con quién vas necesitamos parar
vivimos en un continuo zapping pasamos
del instagram al facebook al youtube al
abrir el correo electrónico hijo mío no
te comas es para un poco creemos que
podemos hacer varias cosas a la vez no
se puede está científicamente demostrado
que cuando estamos conduciendo y
hablando con el teléfono lo que ocurre
es que el cerebro desconecta y hace una
cosa y luego muy rápidos y hacia la otra
pero a la vez no se puede no se puede
hacer dos cosas a la vez
no se puede es que no no tiene sentido
las otras eses son la soledad que gran
compañera que gran compañera de hecho a
veces estoy solo y viene alguien y lo
fastidia
y el silencio y para ilustrar esto
quería mencionar o citar un poema de
edgardo ubaldo poeta uruguayo que dice
habla poco a los hombres y habla mucho
contigo y si buscas al eco que conforta
y consuela
habla el viento que pasa hasta el árbol
amigo al arroyo que corre y al pájaro
que vuela y si después llevando la vida
que te invoco
la soledad te abruma y el silencio te
espanta
asómate a ti mismo verás que poco a poco
tu soledad se puebla y tu silencio canta
mi silencio canto en el año 2001 el 8 de
octubre del 2001 dejé mi trabajo
y aterricé en bolivia la paz con una
bicicleta comenzaba el proyecto
kilómetros de sonrisas recorrí argentina
bolivia ecuador chile perú colombia
venezuela brasil paraguay uruguay
me dado cuenta que cuando recorro el
mundo yo lo traigo suerte a los países
llegué a argentina y me agarró el
corralito del 19 de diciembre del 2001
me agarró el tsunami en japón y cuando
estoy a punto de concluir la vuelta al
mundo entró por pirineos y cataluña
declara la independencia
ya no me quieren por ahí
este proyecto de 1 año y medio del 2001
al 2003 cuando volví escribí un libro se
lo ofrecí a varias editoriales no lo
quisieron publicar menos mal
porque he ganado mucho más publicándolo
yo mismo mediante la autoedición de
hecho lleva cuatro ediciones es lo que
se considera en el mercado hoy en día un
best seller edite un documental y mi
gente me dijo bueno ya se te quitó la
tontería quieres volver a trabajar en la
notaría y o no
ahora es peor
ahora quiero dar la vuelta al mundo
pero me dijo ten cuidado cuando vuelvas
te esperan tres preguntas de que vas a
vivir
dónde
qué harás cuando te jubiles tú no has
cotizado más que cuatro años y medio
estás loco
esas preguntas me mataron
yo no tenía respuesta pero tenía que
cumplir mi sueño porque los sueños
cuando son auténticos te vuelven la vida
patas arriba te lo desordenan todo el
cementerio está lleno de soñadores he
dicho muchas veces yo no voy a ser uno
más yo quiero que el día que venga la
muerte a buscarme decir que tal cómo
estás
no quiero más he vivido llévate lo que
me sobró
esas tres preguntas no las pude
responder y me fui pero un proyecto como
la vuelta al mundo tuve que prepararla
yo trabajaba en una mensajería la luna
yo soy ese de ahí de hecho en la bici
mensajería cuando estaba repartiendo
paquetes la gente me decía
en donde trabajas en la luna
estoy trabajando en la luna y luego me
voy por la tierra a dar una vuelta en
bicicleta
al mediodía iba a clases de francés y a
la tarde preparaba el proyecto de la
vuelta al mundo y este es el proyecto de
la vuelta al mundo
áfrica hasta el cairo tres años oriente
medio japón el tsunami australia-nueva
zelanda a alaska baje hasta ushuaia por
segunda vez llegue un día antes del
invierno brasil y en barco hasta génova
subí a noruega bajé a grecia subía a
italia ver a la reina y volví para
declarar la independencia de cataluña
regresé a oviedo el mismo día que me fui
el 19 de noviembre pero por algún azar
de la vida yo me fue un viernes y volvió
un domingo solo un payaso consigue
llegar el mismo día después de 13 años
de vuelta al mundo fueron 13 años de
vuelta al mundo 178 mil kilómetros son
cuatro veces la vuelta al ecuador de la
tierra 117 países casi 118
esta es
esta es mi casa la bici es mi casa y el
mundo mi jardín
tengo el jardín más grande sin pagar el
ibi esta bicicleta pesa 80 kilos 80 con
la que están llegando hoy los corredores
al giro de italia pesa 67 kilos en esos
80 kilos llevaba a la tienda de campaña
a la cocina repuestos el ordenador para
actualizar mi página web y agua como
veis allá abajo llevaba agua porque
durante casi todos los días de la vuelta
al mundo yo me he duchado no entiendo
eso de ser hippie de si llevo 13 días
sin ducharme tío eres un guarro
te puedes luchar si quieres hay que
cargar con el agua verdad
he dormido en cualquier lugar en
cualquier lugar e tocado las puertas de
miles de hogares he descubierto que el
mundo está lleno de gente buena
sin embargo por alguna cosa en las
noticias solo salen los malos conclusión
apaga la tele desde el año 2001 yo no la
veo para que no es verdad el mundo está
lleno de buenas personas todos y el que
es un cabrón ha tenido un mal día de
verdad piensa así tú tienes un mal día
vemos a la gente otra oportunidad he
visto muchos animales
todos me han respetado esto no es una
pitón es un reductor de velocidad que
ponen en áfrica
está a punto de morir siete veces he
tenido cuatro mal áreas cerebrales esta
es la primera me llegaron a dar la
extremaunción cuando veo al cura digo
pero que hace que que no estoy tan mal
si estaba muy mal
y en esta fotografía que vais a ver a
continuación se ve esa laguna yo pasé
por perú por este paso habrá olímpica
cuatro mil novecientos metros fui la
primera vez en autobús para hacer un
espectáculo no llegaba en bicicleta la
segunda vez por lo que ocurrió en el año
2002 cuando pase en autobús la segunda
vez es este año 2012 subió en bicicleta
lo que ocurrió la primera vez fue que al
llegar arriba
el conductor saltó en marcha
el autobús quedó colgando en el
precipicio tuvimos que salir por la
ventana
el propósito es mejor si consigues
beneficiar a los demás en mi caso soy
payaso y lo que he hecho ha sido regalar
ofrecer mi espectáculo a la gente más
humilde por todo el mundo
campos de refugiados orfanatos cárceles
escuelas lugares donde no me podía ni
siquiera anunciar porque en ese país no
existe la palabra payaso no importa el
nombre importa lo que haces y así he
llevado risas a miles de personas más de
21 mil personas sin duda alguna mi
público favorito es siempre el de la
cárcel porque se quedan hasta el final
del espectáculo
la risa nos acerca la risa es un idioma
si consigues hacer reír como yo les
hecho reír a ustedes tienes un amigo
tienes un puente hay muchas fronteras me
pedían dinero soborno hacia un número de
magia hacía la broma de
se reían hazlo otra vez otra vez
que tienes que pagar 5
le rompía los esquemas eso es lo que
hace la risa nos desbloquea
hablo cinco idiomas sin embargo me doy
cuenta que no es lo mejor hablar inglés
para recorrer el mundo
[Música]
cómo
la people
onlive travel in around the world aids
la palabra diaria públicos mismo
la verdad que muy poco
entender y kalashnikov
cuando volví después de dar la vuelta al
mundo 13 años me seguían esperando las
tres preguntas y descubrir lo siguiente
cuando las miras de frente desaparecen
no existen esas preguntas eran hijas del
miedo y esta es la fórmula del miedo y
si te vas a dar la vuelta al mundo
cuando vuelvas de que vas a vivir el qué
dirán y tus amigos que dirán y tu
familia y la zeta hace la zona de
confort que calentitos está aquí y que
poco aprendes aplica estos tres
componentes y tendrás miedo
dale a este botón en la vida dale a la
pausa y tendrás conocimiento me voy a
despedir con una fórmula elaborada en
mis laboratorios la fórmula pictures
pasión
intuición creatividad esfuerzo
y respeto porque las primeras cuatro
cosas lo tienen los terroristas que
ponen bombas una gran pasión mucha
intuición una gran creatividad y un
esfuerzo de narices pero les falta el
respeto
un día cualquiera de mi vida durante la
vuelta al mundo
[Música]
y recordar que si conseguís tener un
propósito
es posible que no viváis más años
sin embargo
tendréis más vida
dale la vuelta a tu mundo no tengas
miedo
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]